you believe Oh
Wow
hello fallout friends and welcome to an
episode so fast if you run the risk of
spontaneously bursting into carols it's
so jolly you micro a big white beard
over the next five minutes it's so
freakin Christmassy Santa's just handed
in his notice make sure to send us on
your festive and non festive creations
using the hashtag GS fallout and make
sure to stick around for our community
section at the end of the episode where
we'll show off a painting of mr. [__]
and a very festive dogmeat without
further ado let's get stuck into
Christmas you're gonna have to widen
your chimneys because Santa's just got a
whole lot bulkier we preferred his
fluffy cuddly Old South but now that
he's wearing power armor he certainly
looks trimmer he may have to hire a few
more reindeer though with this festive
power armor you can roam around the
wasteland giving drugs to all the good
kids and grenades to the bad ones coal
is far too precious a commodity to waste
on those delinquents we do love to
listen to the radio though there is the
eternal question of why no new music was
written between 1950 and 2077 or at
least why none of it was preserved but
the problem is it's not very Christmassy
everyone knows that Christmas in the
real world is triggered as soon as the
first department store plays the first
few bars of jingle bells so we can only
assume that the same goes for the
fallout world but this mod goes one step
further all the Christmas songs are
period specific so you never have to
feel like it's not 50s enough either and
if Christmas songs trigger Christmas
then ugly jumpers trigger the festive
spirit this one unfortunately doesn't
approach the heights of the hideous
sweater industry's finest work no
pom-poms no musical features no light-up
bits no inappropriate visual jokes about
genitalia but it does include garish
clashing colors and happy little
reindeer sadly it also doesn't come with
matching trousers or a sense of shame or
even a proud grandma smiling beyond the
scenes threatening to make you a new one
next year you probably have heard by now
the Diamond City celebrates Christmas
wants the in-game calendar rolls around
25th of December but what if it's ages
away what if you've already missed it if
you're on PC don't worry there's a mod
for that enter the command for this mod
outside Diamond City and you'll be
instantly transported to the most
wonderful time of the year you will
likely fail all time-related quest but
it's worth it for unlimited
noodles and eggnog and nuka-cola
disclaimer neither of these things exist
so you're dressed like Santa listening
to Christmas music and it's actually
Christmas Day but something's not quite
right
it's the pip-boy that ugly vomit Brown
chunk of wrist candy that loves to
remind you of your alcoholism and
inability to carry another tin can it
would be fine if you could just cover it
in wrapping paper but apparently
wrapping paper doesn't survive a
radiation so well it turns out the
pip-boy has a festive special edition
model the Santa's boy ignoring the
creepy name the Santa's boy gives you an
old-fashioned Pip Boy experience in
glorious red and white just like a candy
cane
but you can't eat those anymore because
of all the radiation sorry so those five
mods should see you through to the new
year and make the Christmas you spend in
the wasteland just a little bit more
festive
today's the part the show where we take
a look at the Christmas presents that
have been sent to us from the fallout
community remember you can send your own
creations comments or builds to us on
Twitter using the hashtag GS fallout but
let's take a look at what's been sensors
this week first of all we've got an
amazing painting of our very own mr.
[__] as you may be aware codsworth can
say quite a variety of names if you do
in fact name your character mr. [__]
well codsworth is gonna honor that and
this very detailed very beautiful
painting of our loyal companion is
extremely well done and plays omage to
her to codsworth wide vocabulary sub
since the holiday season is here but
it's also you know one of the biggest
movie releases of recent memory
someone's actually created an 8080
settlement inside a fallout I got into
incredible detail even going to get the
leg braces the red eyes at the front of
it from afar looks like a be honest it
looks like a giant dog but it's way
better than I think I could have ever
done so major props to both a Fallout
fan and a Star Wars fan for making a
settlement that any Sith Lord would be
proud of and finally something I may
even use on my Christmas card this year
a very festive dogmeat Santa's little
kennel waiting for a nuclear winter to
roll around first of all what else says
holidays other than a happy little face
of your canine companion
so just a few of the community creations
this week but if you want to send us any
more festive surprises feel free to do
so either in the comments or using the
hashtag TS fallout the episode next week
may be a little different so make sure
you tune in and Christmas Eve for a very
Christmasy episode of the fallout 4 show
but until next time thank you all so
much for watching remember to like the
fallout 4 show on YouTube and stay safe
out there wasteland err
with the bow don't sweat now
but he does
gonna burn my truck